let's do another states of matter or
phase change problem and we'll deal with
water again but this one hopefully will
will stretch our neurons a little bit
further so let's say i have 500 grams of
water
500 grams of liquid
liquid water
at
60 degrees
celsius
now my goal is to get it to zero degrees
celsius and the way i'm going to do it
is i'm going to put ice into this 500
grams of water and my ice machine at
home
makes ice
that comes out of the machine at minus
degrees celsius
ice
and my question is exactly how much ice
do i need so how much or how many grams
of ice so how
much
ice do i need to bring my fight and i'm
going to take the ice out of the freezer
and just plop it into my liquid how much
do i need to bring this liquid this 500
grams of liquid water down to zero
degrees
down to zero degrees so the idea i mean
if we just imagine a cup here let me
draw a cup
this is the cup
i have some
some
60 degree water in there i'm going to
plunk
a big chunk of ice in there
a big chunk of ice
and what's going to happen is
is that the water heat from the water is
going to go into the eye so the the ice
will is going to absorb heat from the
water
so the same amount of so in order for
water to go from 60 degrees to zero
degrees i have to extract heat out of it
and we're about to figure out just how
much heat and so we have to say whatever
was extracted out of the water
essentially has to be contained by the
ice and the ice can't get above zero
degrees so essentially that amount of
ice has to absorb all the heat to go
from -10 to zero and then also that that
energy will be used to melt it a bit but
if we don't have enough ice then the ice
is going to go beyond that and then warm
up even more so let's see how we do this
so how much energy do we have to take
out of the 500 grams of liquid water
well it's the same amount of energy that
it would take to put into zero degrees
liquid water and get it to 60 degrees
so we're talking about a 50 degree
change so with the specific so the
energy or the heat that out of the water
heat out
of water is going to be
the specific heat of water half year
from our previous videos
4.178 joules per grams kelvin
so it's 4
4.178
joules per grams kelvin
and i have to multiply that times the
number of grams of water i have to cool
down i have to take the heat out of and
we know that's 500 grams times 500 grams
and then i multiply that times the
temperature differential that we care
about and just a side note i use this
specific heat because we're dealing with
liquid water right we're dealing with
liquid water
liquid water going from 60 to zero so
the final thing i have to multiply it by
the change in temperature the change in
temperature is 60 degrees
times 60
60 degrees there's a little button on
the side of my pen when i press it by
accident sometimes it does that weird
thing so let's see what this is
so this is 4.178
times 500
times 60 change of 60 degrees i could
write it could be a change of 60 degrees
kelvin or a change of 60 degrees celsius
it doesn't matter the actual difference
is the same whether we're doing it
kelvin or celsius
and that's 125
340 joules
so it's 120 so it's equal to 125
340 joules so this is the amount of heat
that you have to take out of 60 degree
water in order to get it down to zero
degrees or this would be the amount of
heat you have to add to zero degree
water to get it to 60 degrees
so essentially our at our ice has to
absorb
this much
energy without going above zero degrees
so how much energy can be can the ice
absorb let's well let's set a variable
the question is how much ice so let's
set our variable
when we call it
do x x is always the unknown variable
so we're going to have x grams
grams
of ice
okay and this it starts at -10 degrees
so when this x grams of ice warms from
minus 10 degrees to zero degrees celsius
how much energy will it be absorbing
so the temperature difference so
to go from
minus 10 degrees celsius to zero degrees
celsius
the heat
that's absorbed by the ice is equal to
so heat
i'll call it heat absorbed
is equal to the specific heat of ice
ice water 2.05 joules per gram kelvin
2.05
joules per gram kelvin times the amount
of ice that's what we're solving for so
times x
times the change in temperature so this
is a 10 degree change in celsius degrees
which is also a 10 degrees change in
kelvin degrees so we could just do 10
degrees i could write kelvin here just
because
at least when i wrote the specific heat
units i have a kelvin in the denominator
it could have been a a celsius but just
to make them cancel out this is of
course x grams so the grams cancel out
so the heat absorbed to go from
minus 10 degree ice to zero degree ice
is
see 2.05 times 10 is
20.5 so it's 20.5
times x
great joules
joules this would go from -10 degrees to
zero degrees
now once we're zero degrees the ice can
even absorb more
more energy before increasing in
temperature as it melts right remember
when you draw you draw that phase change
diagram you the ice gains some energy
and then it levels out as it gets as it
melts as the the bonds the the hydrogen
bonds are kind of start sliding past
each other and the crystalline structure
breaks down so this amount of energy the
ice can also absorb and that so this is
zero degree
we do it in a different color
zero degree ice
to zero
i did it again to zero degree water
zero degree water
well the heat absorbed now is going to
be
the heat of fusion of ice or the heat
the melting heat either one that's 333
joules per gram
it's equal to 333
joules per gram times the number of
grams we have once again that's x
grams they cancel out so the
ice will absorb
333.55
joules as it goes from zero degree ice
to zero degree water
so the total amount or 333.55
x
joules let me put that x there that's
key so the total amount of heat that the
ice can absorb without going above zero
degrees because once it's zero degree
water as you put more heat into it it's
going to get it's going to start getting
warmer again we if the ice gets above
zero degrees there's no way it's going
to bring the water down to zero degrees
so the ice cannot get or the at this
point the water can't get above zero
degrees so how much total heat can our
ice absorb
so
heat absorbed
is equal to the heat it can absorb when
it goes from -10 to 0 degrees ice and
that's 20.5
x
where x is the number of grams of ice we
have
plus the amount of heat we can absorb as
we go from zero degree ice to zero
degree water and that's 333.55
x and of course all of this is joules so
this is the total amount of heat that
the ice can absorb without going above
zero degrees now how much real energy
does it have to absorb well it has to
absorb all of this 125
340 joules of energy out of the water
because that's the amount of energy we
have to extract from the water to bring
it down to zero degrees
so the amount of ice the energy absorbs
or the amount of energy the ice absorbs
has to be this 125 340. so that has to
be equal to
340 joules
see we can do a little bit of algebra
here add these two things 20.5 x plus
333.55 x
is what it's 350
x is that right yeah 330 plus 20 is 350
then you have a three but you have a 0.5
there at 354.05 x that is equal to
the amount of energy we take out of the
water
and you divide both sides so x is equal
to 125
340 divided by 354.05
i'll take out the calculator for this
calculator
the calculator tells me to see 125
340 the amount of energy that has to be
absorbed by the ice
divided by
354.05
is equal to
grams roughly there's a little bit of
extra so actually just to be careful
maybe i'll take 355 grams of ice because
i definitely want my water to be chilled
so our answer is x is equal to 354.02
grams of ice so if i take so this is
interesting i had
500 grams of liquid and you know
intuitively i said oh boy if i have to
bring that down to zero degrees i'd have
to have a ton of ice but it turns out i
only need what was the exact number
350 this is so the liquid is 500 grams
about roughly half a pound if you want
to get a sense for how much 500 grams is
a kilograms 2.2 pounds
so this ice is 354 so you actually have
to have less ice than water
which is interesting because it seems
like the ice isn't making that big of a
temperature change the ice is only going
from minus 10 to zero degrees while the
water is going all the way from
60 degrees to zero degrees so you're
like well you know how does that work
out and the reason is because so much
energy can be absorbed by the ice in the
form of potential energy as it melts so
the heat of fusion so if you talk about
all of the energy that the ice absorbing
most of it is due to the heat of fusion
right there so the ice can absorb you
can actually have zero degree ice and it
can still absorb this huge amount of
energy just just by melting it without
even changing its temperature anyway
hopefully you found that reasonably
useful